welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about whether or
not an older magic man in a cape and a
precious young boy can get along i think
so i mean as long as you know they work
together to save the universe i think
there's a relationship that's all
they're doing then that's fine that's
all you really need my name is mt and
i'm here today with my big question
brother off-screen producer brandon
what's going on brandon hello mt so
happy to be back you know i just want
the world to forget that i was ever
brandon
off-screen producer off-screen producer
can you make that happen empty i will
make it happen i'm going to talk to
stephen because steven don't give a damn
about the rules of the universe he will
make everyone forget your original name
you don't care no more you're asking
producer brandon now
perfect that's all i ever wanted but hit
me with that big question off-screen
producer
oh i would love to empty we've got
spider-man no way home just over the
horizon yeah we've gotten a few sneak
peeks from the trailers about how this
story might unfold and while it looks
like our friend peter parker is going to
be facing off against some villains from
across
the multiverse from other dimensions
other universes other timelines i'm also
wondering if he's going to be facing a
threat in his very own backyard and i'm
not talking aunt may oh i'm talking
somebody
even worse even more deadly even more
deadly than may with a frying pan oh my
god impossible she's gotten tangled
folks she's got a frying pan now it all
leads us to today's big question mt and
spiderman no way home are spiderman and
doctor strange gonna be friends or are
they gonna be enemies
that is a great question brandon and you
would think that this would be an easy
question to answer since you know both
spider-man and doctor strange have both
solely been on the side of good the good
boys in the mcu so far yeah they're good
boys but i do agree that between the
trailers that have been released and the
recent actions of doctor strange in the
you know the what if series it does make
us wonder if this friendship is doomed
to sink and go down the water spout like
the itsy bitsy spider that went up the
water spout and then the rain came down
oh my god and watch the spot i just
dropped something
so we are going to look at all the
evidence that we have so far and see if
we can make our best guesses about which
side of the battle these two will be on
so let us start by looking at some
instances in the comics where the web
slinger and the mastic of the mystic
arts have crossed paths in the past and
one of these comics was even an easter
egg inside of the no way home trailer on
a license plate on one of the cars in
the background and that comic is marvel
team up number a 21. because in marvel
team up number 21 from 1974 doctor
strange and spider-man do cross paths
thanks to the interference of one evil
sorcerer zandu zandu zandu uh he's a
famous marvel comics villain everyone
knows about zandu kids can't stop
talking about zandu it's everyone's
always asking when's andrew gonna show
up in the mcu the kids love zandu every
time i walk into a comic book store
people are like yo are you empty i'm
like of course i they're like where's
andrew coming i'm like bro i'm trying to
live my life why is it always saying
doing this because in that story zandu
poses as a mugging victim in order to
put spider-man under a hypnotic spell
and then he then uses his spider puppet
to steal the crystal of cadavers from
doctor strange because you ain't gonna
steal it some other way doctor strange
got security all over that mansion you
ain't gonna get in yeah he's got simply
safe yeah you know
he's got sim simply
oh that's pretty good that's pretty good
and zandy wants to use this crystal to
restore the wand of a tomb and bring his
betrothed back to life from the dead
which is what wizards love to do
apparently when they have magic it's
like you know what if i got a dead
girlfriend bring her back for the dead
because you know dating sites are empty
it's so hard it's so hard to get a girl
out there or a man or whoever you're
looking for it's hard to find a partner
so if they die on you you gotta work
hard exactly bring them back from the
dead yo recycling that's what the wave
is these days don't you don't get a new
you don't get a new party recycle the
old one of course we saw the wand of a
tomb in doctor strange yeah i think
that's what uh wong one he picks it up
oh yeah they don't call it out i don't
think yeah but he's like hold on let me
get my beating stick cuz i got a bk
silliest that son of a [ __ ] okay
celia's come back around here i'll get
that wand out i mean juan doesn't want
to get his head cut off it's hard being
the librarian dude right jesus everyone
wants that knowledge that uh that
librarian book knowledge and while
spider-man and doctor strange do face
off in this storyline steven knows
spider-man is under a spell and pulls
his magic punches because man if steven
punches you with the full might of his
fist of sidorak oh boy uh your face is
is going to be in another reality uh
easily your face will be punched off i'm
into uh earth 1610 for sure guaranteed
but eventually peter breaks free of the
spell and the two take on zandu together
and doctor strange even casts a spell
that causes this two to switch powers
with spider-man shooting magic bulbs and
doctor strange slang in that web like oh
my god i want to see spider strange so
badly that would be awesome to see in no
way home is if they switch powers just
for a little bit to see yeah uh
spider-man shooting out some magic
that'd be pretty cool i also want uh dr
street to have uh peter parker's puberty
as well
he's like oh no not this why am i horny
all the time this is so weird again
not again but yeah perhaps the easter
egg reference to the trailer means that
our two heroes might face off in the
film but one of them is under some type
of evil control maybe
i don't know who knows yeah i mean that
would make sense i don't see a good
reason for these two
of sound mind and body to just start
fighting for no reason right they've
worked hard together they've
brought back all these people if for
whatever reason they do start fighting
someone's being manipulated up here i
think they're i mean i think the only
good reason that those two would
probably fight is if uh stephen strange
said that zendaya is not that hot i
think that's a good
i mean
the gloves come off at that point yeah
come find me stephen come fight yo what
the [ __ ] did you just say about my girl
this is a spider foo right here this is
what uh
spider food like come here i'll give you
the old one too spider fool let's go
okay so that was a great example empty
very and it's very interesting that
that's the that is an easter egg they
maybe really want us to think about this
comic i don't think we'll see zandu in
this film but maybe
someone else is going to be doing a
little mind control maybe
we can't really say it around here
anymore mephisto
well the n word
the m word i don't know
but we'll have to see it why was this in
the trailer why did they give us this
easter egg you know they could just be
throwing out spider-man comics with
doctor strange in spider-man but i don't
know i don't know i'm on zandu watch bro
i'm still on zandu we're on zandu watch
can't wait for xander to come to the mcu
because you got to think about it like
zandu could be like this
interdimensional force in the mcu and
like with you know sheng shi um
introducing like interdimensional beings
in the what if series um i think that
it's possible i mean it's it's unlikely
but because of this license plate we we
can't discount a zan do appearance we
can't because it's a very strong one you
know we did get eliath in loki and that
was that's obscure as they get like no
one was thinking about goliath before
loki guy come on nobody okay so empty
the next storyline we're going to check
out is ultimate marvel team up number 13
from 2002. okay and this storyline takes
place in the ultimates universe and it's
an homage to the spider and the
sorcerer's story that you just talked
about so once again it involves our good
friend the evil sorcerer zandu
and it's all about his quest to obtain
that good old wand of what tomb uh but
like i said this is in the ultimate
universe so this is a totally different
universe uh from the main marvel
universe 1610. your storyline happened
yes so yeah this is our 1610 and the one
before is earth 616. so zandu once again
takes control of spiderman uh and he
sends him to kill doctor strange
uh but you know doc's not having any of
that uh so he zaps like both him and
spider-man into the astral dimension to
kind of knock the mind control out of
spider-man so they can kind of like
figure things out um but what's most
interesting about this specific
storyline is it really revolves around
spider-man's secret identity because in
the ultimate universe at this time no
one really knew who spider-man was he's
still very fresh he's new on the scene
dr strange like sees peter without the
spider-man mask on
and it forces them to kind of
build a bond together
so that's that's really important uh
because this you know this no way home
is all about everyone finding about
spiderman's identity and him wanting to
undo it all right so it's very
interesting to take this comic story
line into consideration when we think
about what might happen in no way home
um
so yeah there's maybe some clues there
again zandu again we're going to talk
zantoo shows up a lot anytime spiderman
and doctor strange cross paths i don't
think we'll ever see him in the mcu
maybe we'll see him as like an
amalgamation of characters you know yeah
kind of like how they did with
uh sylvie uh in the series she was kind
of a mixture of lady loki and
enchantress right uh so you know they
could take the concept of zandu this
other sorcerer who wants to stop doctor
strange or get something from doctor
strange so he mind control somebody uh
that could that could happen but yeah uh
there is a little fighting between
doctor strange and and spider-man in
this one but again it's because of mind
control not because they hate each other
because some outside influence is
forcing them to fight in our next comics
team up comes from the year 1998 where i
was just a wee six-year-old in
kindergarten or first grade i don't know
uh but i was definitely crying uh in the
untold state
i was definitely i was 100 i was a
crybaby boy when i was a young child it
was pop in on me anytime in 1998 i'm
crying
and this is of course the untold tales
of spider-man strange encounter and this
storyline was strictly a team-up and so
there's no fighting each other in this
because you know we we can't see those
two very nice boys fighting each other
it just breaks my heart breaks my heart
every time and this storyline is a
flashback to supposedly the first time
spider-man and doctor strange met back
when peter was still in high school and
they team up to retrieve a magical item
known as the lantern of lantar which is
a great name for a lantern and in the
process perfect literally about the time
amazing day for like
it must have taken them several days
to make that name for those of you at
home uh it's spelled lantar spelled
l-a-n-t-a-r-r and it follows like the
magic magical element of like we'll just
throw two of the same uh letters right
next to each other like the wand of with
two has like the two i was like with an
extra r
and in the process they also wind up
taking on dormammu and baron motor who
are both villains who threatened
spider-man's loved ones which is you
don't do that one of my favorite things
is when peter parker was going crazy
trying to save aunt may um after the
whole you know her getting shot during
the one more day storyline because he
was just you lost his mind so like you
don't mess with peter parker's family
you know i mean he almost killed that
guy because of uncle ben you know what i
mean like it's like you could beat up
spider-man as what you as much as you
want he'll just tie up with some webs
but you come after his family he's gonna
he's gonna he's gonna lose his cool
exactly like one of my favorite
spider-man moments is when uh kingpin is
in prison and spider-man goes into
prison and threatens kingpin's life in
front of everybody and keeping him
sweating like he's sweating he's like oh
my god maybe i shouldn't have threatened
his loved ones that was a terrible idea
i'm just a man he's a spidered man he's
a spiderman
that's kingpin's number one problem
right mt is that because his power his
ability is just being tough and like
fighting and beating people up like ever
he always pushes heroes to be like all
right that's it i'm gonna beat you up
now i'm gonna beat you as hard as i can
it's like poor guy i mean he's just
that's what he does you know don't get
so mad all the time he's kingpin
spiderman come on spider-man
my favorite kingpin is the one from
under the spider verse because just the
accent
it's not always about the money
spider-man
spider-man it's about the mets it's
about the meds baby it's all about the
mets
it's all about the mets
this is an interesting one shot to
consider since both dormammu and baron
motorola have already been introduced
inside of the mcu and we know that mordo
is coming back in multiverse of madness
but could he make an earlier appearance
in spider-man no way home and
what about dormammu i mean he's bound to
be a threat again one of these days
because like he only stopped taking over
everything because of a bargain because
he was like all right i'm kind of stuck
here he got a logic puzzle he was like
all right i've had enough i'm annoyed
yeah but like yeah dormammu eventually
he's gonna be like wait what what why
didn't i take over
i'm gonna go back right i think i could
take it this time i mean if he waits
like a couple hundred years i mean
doctor strange might be dead anyway so
it'd be very easy unless he goes the
ancient one route and starts stealing
that that dark magic to stay alive could
be could be i don't know strange supreme
would do it he would totally be he lived
he lived for thousands of years but yeah
it's a great point because dormammu's
got to come back eventually and yeah we
know baron mordo's going to show up uh
in multiverse of madness but he could
make his first entrance and no way home
maybe he's the one that's like tricking
doctor strange into being a little weird
and doing this very unsafe spell that he
appears to be doing in no way home maybe
mordo and dormammu have like teamed up
this time
and uh mordo is gonna with the help of
dormam who's gonna be like look i'm
gonna take care of all the sorcerers on
earth and get rid of them and then you
can have earth because i'm sick of it
no for real and i think like because of
like the the events of loki um sort of
like kicking off this like sort of
multiversal war scenario with all these
games you have to think that there are
other players on the multiversal scale
that are one in on this like you have
dormamma right yeah potentially
shumagorath like there's all these
multiversal beings that want control of
everything and so dormammu has to come
back he has to come back all right mt
next let's let's take a look at marvel
team-up annual number five from 1982. uh
this storyline is titled serpent rising
and in this comic we see spider-man and
doctor strange team up again along with
the scarlet witch
the thing uh and everyone's favorite
quasar quasar i love quasar and this
interesting team uh they're they're
they're dealing with uh the reptilian
demon set uh and the dimensional
apocalypse he's trying to unleash on our
dimension but what's most important
about this storyline is strange uses a
mystical object known as the cosmic cube
to defeat set
he drains all the power out of the
cosmic cube and that's how he's able to
like kind of push set out of our
dimension
now this is interesting because like
cosmic cubes they've appeared a lot in
marvel comics
[Music]
[Applause]
they're they kind of look like the
tesseract uh usually like they're these
glowing cubes they can control matter
and energy based on the will of the
sentient being that wields them right so
they're essentially like wish granters
like if you want something you have this
cosmic cube you can kind of make it
happen it can like alter reality and all
those things right
we know in the trailer we see this weird
cube thing uh that they're holding uh
like spiderman's holding it when doctor
strange does that like astral punch on
him knocks him out of his body right
like we don't know what this cube thing
is it could be a cosmic cube now it's
not a glowing cube but they've kind of
already done that with the tesseracts so
i think for audiences they'd want to
make it look different yeah so this
could be like a cosmic cube like there's
also in marvel comics there's not just
one cosmic cube right they kind of come
and go you know depending on the
storyline they show up and someone has
like the power to use it but it could be
like this this comic storyline could
give us a little hint about what we
might see in the way home is this cosmic
cube what causes all these villains to
come from other dimensions and stuff is
someone trying to get this cosmic cube
out of the sanctum santorum could it be
zandu who knows
uh
chance at 96
so according to my calculations so yeah
is this weird cube thing we're seeing is
it a cosmic cube and cosmic cubes are
super powerful like they've often been
said to be like as powerful as an
infinity stone 100 so this could be like
a very dangerous device especially in
evil hands
and i love that you brought up the
cosmic cube thing because like recently
in the comics the cosmic cube is so so
powerful that it made hydra cap i don't
know if you remember that whole hydra
people were upset i can't believe
captain america was hydra the whole time
he wasn't the cosmic cube literally
rewrote reality so that he was uh this
hydra person the entire time yeah so
it's literally has like wanda maximoff
level powers in this little box and no
way home seems to be breaking down the
walls of this universe's reality so
exactly uh it could be a cosmic cube
maybe mine may be i i like i didn't even
consider that i like that i really like
that a lot and one more comic storyline
that we should look at is marvel team up
number 80 from 1979 and in this story
titled a sorcerer possessed doctor
strange is the one that gets cursed this
time not peter parker oh okay finally
finally doctor strange gets cursed it's
about time but when he gets cursed this
time he turns into a werewolf-like
creature and goes on a rampage i love
when marvel turns their heroes into
werewolves it should happen at least
once for everybody yeah i mean they've
done the zombie storyline do the
werewolf story exactly come on we wanna
yo like we have into the spider verse we
have into the venomverse like let's get
into you the werewolver like this
werewolf world he does look pretty funny
in the comic ft because it's like a
werewolf in dr strange's outfit and
you're like what is going on yo it's
that's that's a badass look to me man i
love that man it's just so stupid
guys it was the late 70s
anything anything to get people to buy a
comic book they did back in the day it's
like any gimmick it's like all right
well wolf stephen strange they'll buy it
the kids will do anything it makes sense
it makes sense but yeah he even attacks
peter parker's date which is a no-no
like you don't [ __ ] block when you turn
into a werewolf that's like the last
thing you do jesus christ and unlike
other marvel team-up story lines where
doctor strange is usually the
level-headed one in charge this time
spider-man has to take the lead because
you know he's a werewolf and teams up
with other magical beings like clea and
doctor strange's uh girlfriend or love
interest and satana which is satan with
an a to help subdue werewolf strange and
undo the curse and this is a very
important comic storyline to consider
because it shows that doctor strange can
also be manipulated into being the
villain so i mean we've watched the
trailer mt and it's like he does it does
seem like something's up
with steven strange right he's not
acting
like we're used to he's not level-headed
he's being a little careless
you know maybe he's just feeling like uh
you know we saved the universe so i can
i could do whatever i'm i'm the
sorcerer's supreme now there's no
ancient one holding me back
okay i can do whatever i magically wrong
get out of here and do whatever magic i
want okay it would be interesting if
like spider-man is the one who has to be
because he's always looking for like
mentors right right he always did
whatever tony told him to do pretty much
uh and you know and far from home he
kind of learned to be like all right i
got to be the boss now but it's clear in
this film you know he's going to stephen
asking for help like how could you help
me do this right um but if he some along
the way figures out that like oh
something's up with with doctor strange
i gotta like i gotta take the lead i
gotta make the decisions i gotta be the
big boy i gotta fix things i feel like
peter parker throughout these films like
he just gets more and more
responsibility and like that's what
makes the homecoming trilogy really
great to me he's just learning how to be
a responsible hero whereas in this
situation like you said strange is
acting really sketchy really strange
[Music]
that's why we paid the big bucks brandon
they pay me big bucks you're getting
paid where is it going
you are making
500 000
and you were only gonna pay me 30.
you're getting 30 grand i'm getting a
thousand
you guys are getting paid but i i am
ready for like adult uh peter parker
that's what i really liked about into
the spider verse with peter b parker he
seemed like a grown-up oh hell yeah
spider-man who's like he's got the years
he's got the experience like that's the
frustrating thing with the spider-man
films is they're always resetting and
putting it back in high school over
again it's like no i want like 40 year
old spider yes what's it like to be him
seriously i want i want us to grow up
with spider-man throughout the years if
we can like if
tom holland wants to do it for the rest
of his life i say we just let him do it
why not tom sign that 30-year contract
seriously let it die i want to see that
man like web slinging when he's like 70.
but yes those are just a small sample of
the storylines where peter and steven
have crossed paths whether at odds or on
the same team and there are plenty more
instances in the comics but those are
the ones that just really stood out to
us but what about what we know about
spidey and strange in the mcu because
that's all that matters these days it's
a marvel cinematic universe all that
matters okay we haven't officially met
cool
but they've only really interacted on
screen in infinity war and end game so
let's go through some of those points
where they interacted or may have
interacted because at first of course
they meet up on the spaceship leading to
an unknown location and it's kind of
awkward for peter who assumes that
they're both using made up names which
is one of my favorite parts oh we're
using our made up names oh i'm spiderman
i'm peter by the way doctor strange oh
using their made-up names um
i'm spider-man then
uh i'm spider-man you fictional man you
silly man but yeah and then stephen also
asked if peter is tony's ward which is
also hilarious
billions of miles from earth with no
backup i'm back up no you're still away
the adults are talking i'm sorry i i'm
confused as to the relationship here i
mean what what is he your ward got him
take that batman
and then of course peter sees a lot of
bickering between stephen and his mentor
tony yeah i think that's like a really
pivotal thing that we don't really think
about a lot because peter he's like he's
latched on to the spaceship uh tony
tried to get rid of him with the
parachute but he's hung around he's
snuck on he's like a stowaway and like
he helps iron man like blow uh
what's his face
there's the old he helps him blow what's
his face interesting
the black guard guy uh
black guard
pete davis the magic one
ebony ma ebony ma thank god okay so
peter's like snuck onto the spaceship
you know he doesn't know what's going on
he's helped tony uh blow ebony ma out
into space with that classic film aliens
that really inspired him and now he's
met
doctor strange for the first time and
the first thing he sees is like doctor
strange and tony like kind of fighting
and like dr strange being like no shut
up you have a big ego like i'll tell you
what to do and like kind of bickering
and like i'm sure immediately you know
peter is like don't don't talk to my
fake dad
who do you think you are like that's my
dad okay it's that's like a heavy moment
it's like the first time you see your
own father like getting a fight with
somebody like
who's disagreeing with my dad my dad
could beat up your dad okay so you
better stop exactly
i think it's really important to
consider that peter's first impression
of doctor strange is like who is this
[ __ ] right who is this guy i don't i
don't know if i can trust this guy
because my dad doesn't seem to trust him
that much my mentor the guy i look up to
the most he doesn't seem to trust this
guy or thinks he's wrong uh so i think
that's like a really pivotal moment to
consider
their interactions going forward but yes
and then after that stephen does his
time stone future peaking thing while on
the planet of titan and then off screen
they come up with a plan to fight thanos
so i'm sure that there was a bit of you
know
feeling each other out and learning
about each other there and then of
course spider-man and doctor strange
fight well together and have some very
fun uh kick-punching portal action i
just one of my favorite parts of that
movie uh punching with the kick i wonder
if they like when they were waiting for
like thanos to show up if they were like
practice
he was like all right i'm going to make
two portals
uh spider-man now jump through him i
don't want to jump through your crazy
portals like they must have practiced
right right it's not his first oh yeah
definitely like peter when he did that
middle finger boom thing he definitely
did at least once before he did yeah
because like you don't do that the first
time
so so it shows that like even though
they had that awkward like uh initial
meeting they probably talked a little on
the planet and felt each other out and
then worked well together they worked
really well together yeah for sure but
not well enough because they lose you
know
spoiler alert they lose and then have
some off-screen post-fight time together
before they both dust off into oblivion
and then i guess i assume he sees
probably
you know tony gets stabbed and almost
died and he sees like steven give up the
time stone and then thanos kind of whoop
zaps away right
and then the events happen in wakanda
that we see as the audience but like
just on the planet they're just kind of
waiting around probably like oh okay i
guess we're stuck on this
destroyed planet now what do we do now
and then at some point all of a sudden
they're just like
you know like out of nowhere because
they don't know what's happening on
earth right not at all so that's that's
pretty crazy there's probably a lot of
well you [ __ ] up no you [ __ ] up
peter quill this is all your fault
[Music]
yes i hope they all just like just
slapped peter quill i'm sure they were
all there was a line up to just a slap
peter quill like when everyone came back
from this now i hope everyone just lined
up and just slapped peter quill before
the final battle at any game i mean a
lot of things went wrong before that but
that was this is
things going wrong moment but i mean in
theory you know dr strache saw all those
possible outcomes he must have known yes
that like peter was going to screw up
and he kind of needs peter quill to
screw up in a way i don't know and like
that's a really good point because like
i wonder in regards to like you know
peer in doctor strange relationship if
peter resents strange for letting his
dad die we can i love him i just keep
talking about his dad i will give that a
100 yeah it's just easy to call tony
exactly so i hope that like there's a
point of tension or like something
happens between the two was just like
you let tony die you son of a [ __ ] i
can't even believe you because that has
to be boiling up within him and honestly
uh steven sort of owes him one at that
point so yeah rewrite reality why not
he's like you can have zendaya and aunt
may or you can have tony and in that
case i get it i say bye tony i'm sorry
bye
you had a nice life like thanks for the
suit uh i got zendaya and then of course
like we just said in endgame they both
get brought back together and then
immediately go back to fighting because
that's what heroes do
violence yeah we are resorting to
violence for the nintendo wii
i wonder uh how bad the eye crusties
were after coming back from the snap oh
i was like god did you re-dust i don't
know but that's pretty much all we get
until spider-man no way home and peter
go through all the events of far from
home of course but we assume it's
without any interaction from strange and
in the movies nick fury even says that
strange is occupied and he's not
available right um to help him out okay
um doctor strange unavailable and from
the trailer uh it looks like their first
time interacting since the events of
endgame and peter is still awkwardly
working out how to even address doctor
strange because he's just like oh what
do i even call like we're not friends at
this point but you're an adult we're not
like co-workers
[Laughter]
we're partners co-workers so it's clear
he doesn't see himself on the same level
as the sorcerer supreme and capitulates
to his ideas because he's the one in
charge he's the older one yeah he he
comes to him for help and peter's like
what should i do and doctor schneider's
like well we could do this pretty
dangerous stuff and wong's like
see you later buddy it's like all right
guys you guys gonna [ __ ] things up i'm
leaving i'm out of here yeah but yeah
peter does come to stephen after all
because he's missing his mentor tony and
needs someone with slick facial hair to
tell him what to do because that's yeah
that's what this patient here is about
can't make his own decisions still he
doesn't know what to do yeah like it's
the reason i grew up facial hair uh
brandon is because people respect my
authority when i uh it's smart it's very
smart i wish i could grow facial hair
you will one day but the trailer does
make it seem like they fight at some
point because of the whole train
sequence like that doesn't seem like
they're on good terms here it seems like
doctor strange is like all right you
want to mess with me have a bunch of
trains you dumb teenage boy because
that's the one thing most spider-man
have to deal with is a trait at one
point because that happens in the tokyo
trains in spider-man
it's always popping off it's new york
yeah that that whole train thing does
not look like oh we're friends and we're
getting along and i'm just gonna show
you what i can do with trains and magic
no it looks like a fight
and also there's that astral punch that
dr strange unleashes on people yeah
which is
you know yeah
and traditionally those have been used
in the films as like uh
like getting your attention moment or
like hey just chill out for a second or
let me show you how powerful i am but
this time it did look like a little
aggressive i don't know uh it's yeah it
does look like they got a fight at some
point they're gonna come to blows yeah
and like this is like the first time
that that a push like that has happened
in public because doctor strange pushed
rapidly
and the hulk push happened on the
rooftop and so this one happened in the
middle of the street so for him to do
that to push a teenage boy in the middle
of the street that's a bad look so like
it just seems like they're fighting at
that point for sure and we can't also
forget that strange supreme that was
introduced in what if like we know that
stephen is capable of having a dark side
and putting his own needs before the
greater good so maybe you know we could
see this manifesting in the main marvel
universe with this new doctor with our
doctor stranger rather yeah i mean it is
because they did kind of say that those
what-if things are canon to the mcu so
you know could this strange supreme have
somehow like crossed over into you know
the mcu and has taken over the doctor
strange that's here and he's put the
regular doctor strange in a little a
little crystal ball somewhere hiding
away i don't know we did leave what if
with like you know strange supreme kind
of having to watch watch killmonger and
zola to make sure that they stay in
their their little cube but i don't know
maybe he got out and he's like i'm gonna
go mess things up in the mcu now and
like um a lot of people have suspected
that the doctor strange in norway home
is mephisto
i mean i don't think it's mephisto
myself but like if it is mephisto i feel
like what if could potentially be using
the whole show as a medium as this one
big like mephisto origin story with
strange supreme i think that'd be a very
smart way to do mephisto they wouldn't
have like a lot of the connections that
mephisto has in the comics with you know
the devil and like religious
imagery that i feel like a lot of
countries are not really uh about
showing that so like i feel like this is
disney's way of like all right it's not
the actual devil it's just doctor
strange when he's just being a bad boy
um so i think that maybe we could see
like it could be that what if strange um
being evil and uh trying to manipulate a
small child as you know one should not
do in real life but villains don't care
they do not give a damn
[Laughter]
yeah and as we were saying before like
you know the mcu loves to blend comic
characters together and make them into
one character or a whole new character
and you know shang chi introduced the
dweller in darkness like could that be
an amalgamation of like mephisto and the
dwelling in darkness could it just be
this like evil force and it's kind of
one and the same like you know it could
be either the dull of the darkness or
any type of multiversal threat because
as we saw with like as dr strange was
eating all these creatures there's a
whole host of interdimensional creatures
and beings that we have no clue that are
out there
little evil gnomes out little gnomes it
could be a gnome controlling doctor
strange who knows an evil gnome um i
hope it's an evil no that'd be
hilarious i will cry laughing
if it's something stupid like that like
the sixth villain is an evil dome from
the multiverse but no before we continue
brandon
just let's just answer this ourselves
who do you like do you think that spidey
and strange will be friends or foes in
spider-man 3 no way home that's a good
question empty it's the big question
it's the big moment i do i think they're
gonna be foes at one point and i don't
think it's gonna be uh because they're
of the right mind i think doctor strange
is being influenced and i really like
this idea that either like dormammu or
the dwell in darkness or someone is
influencing him or has replaced him in
like a weird way i don't know why wong
wouldn't have like caught on to it and
is like leaving the situation
from their snowy sanctum sanctorum but
you know i think i think something
suspicious is going on and i do think
they're gonna come to blows at some
point so it's their enemies with an
asterisk okay it's it's not it they
don't mean to be enemies but they're
going to be enemies okay well brandon i
think that doctor strange and spider-man
will be friends in this movie and i
think that you know the reason why i
mean i feel like doctor strange would
have helped spider-man out in far from
home if he was around because that they
just buddies like that but i think that
doctor strange and wong were probably
out in outer space probably trying to
pick up all of the the wreckage from the
asgardian destruction because you got to
think about this the vault from
asgard was filled with magical items and
wow
yeah and storing magical items from this
universe is literally dr strange's job
so he probably went out and just grabbed
all the stuff including the casket of
ancient winters from 4-1 and i think
that is why the entirety of the sanctum
sanctorum is full of snow is because the
the castle
cracked during the explosion and now
it's just like malfunctioning and caused
all the snow to go everywhere a lot of
people think that some sketchy stuff was
going on and he was like you know being
possessed during that time in far from
home when he was not around i think that
he was just
doing his job and like doing uh just
collecting magical items
that's a really interesting idea too
because maybe that's where that weird
cube thing came from that could have
been an odin's vault too right but then
he had to collect that thing
oh very interesting maybe we didn't see
that i like that idea because like if it
is like a cosmic cube of sorts or you
know some type of magical object it
would make sense for it to come from
odin's vault because odin was also
keeping things safe himself i like that
brandon okay but in preparation for this
movie please hit up our shop at
newrockstarsmerch.com because our
partners at epic hero shop have all
kinds of cool clothing and gear inspired
by your favorite property so keep your
eye out for some very cool eternals and
hawkeye inspired designs dropping in the
very very very near future and in the
meantime grab a shang chi or one
division shirt and be the toast of the
town or at least the toast of your local
comic book shop or a mind controlled
town in new jersey either one of those
um i hear the mind control town in new
jersey is quite poppin
very nostalgic feeling um but
and shopping at new rockstarsmerch.com
is an awesome way to support this
channel and show the world your love for
your favorite fandoms but before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the people that help us bring
big question to you people like
draftkings basketball is back you know
basketball that thing lebron james does
when he's not filming space jam movies
draftkings the leader in daily fantasy
sports is celebrating the return to the
hardwood by giving new customers a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes and playing daily fantasy hoops
is super easy just pick your lineup of
pro players stay under the salary cap
and rack up the points for three
pointers rebounds assists and all other
stats that basketball people like to
follow for
uh for a very long time because that's
sports
sports super sports hooray score big and
you can score big cash and with a free
shot at millions of dollars in total
prizes it is literally the perfect time
to show off your basketball iq and
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
and best of all you can deposit and
withdraw your cash whenever you want
literally whatever like they're very
flexible like that so download
draftkings app now and use the promo
code big question all one word big
question and this week new customers can
get a free shot at millions of dollars
in total prizes so please enter promo
code big question to get a free shot at
millions in total prizes with your first
deposit that is code big question no
space big question only at
draftkings.com minimum five dollar
deposit required eligibility
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
for details what would you do if you
didn't have high interest loans or
credit card debt travel more save for
retirement finally finish that one-fifth
scale avengers tower replica in your
backyard dreams do come true with
upstart you can pay off your existing
debt quickly and easily and start living
your life upstart is a fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over a
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan you can
check your rate without impacting your
credit score in minutes for loans
between 1000 to fifty thousand dollars
you can even receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com big question that's
upstart.com big question don't forget to
use our url to let them know that we
sent you loan amounts will be determined
based on your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application upstart.com
bigquestion all right well thank you for
that brandon now it is time for our bite
size questions
eat it up eat it up everybody eat it up
kids they're bite-sized brandon our
first bite size question is because you
know with eternals just around the
corner right on the horizon uh eric saw
it before i did i'm very upset who are
the fastest heroes and villains in the
marvel comics because we got makari
coming up and she's quick she's a quick
one just quick just quick yes this
question comes from giannis jules on
discord thank you giannis when i put
together this list i didn't think it was
fair to consider characters who could
fly
transform into energy
i didn't want them on the list that's
cheating i want to see heroes and
villains who are pumping those legs to
get the true speed on the ground you
know what i mean yeah so that means
while someone like the silver surfer
might be able to move with the power of
the cosmos i don't think it should count
he's got a surfboard it's not fair he's
not running i wanna see him on the
ground running okay so there's quite a
few speedsters in marvel comics there's
a lot of them okay certainly more than i
could name off the top of my head i
would have been shunned at any sort of
trivia contest but i picked out a few of
my faves for this answer so let's get
into it do it we're gonna start with an
og marvel speedster he goes by the name
whizzer that's what i do at 3am every
night my friend um it's
i can't help it can't sleep through the
night because i'm a woman i'm a wizard
man you're a wizard harry i'm a what
yeah wizard he's old school he first
appeared in usa comics number one back
in 1941 which was created by jack kirby
and charles nicholas uh and whizzer this
is great this is so golden age i love it
whizzer got his super speed from an
infusion of mongoose blood oh natural
he got like bit by a cobra and there was
also a mongoose there and the blood got
mixed in i don't know i don't know but
it made him fast however his speed only
tops out at like 100 miles per hour so
that's like fast for like 1941 but it's
he's certainly not the fastest runner
there is but that's the wizard is great
i had to include him on the list it's
he's got a funny name it's it's it's
beautiful and also he was in uh jessica
jones briefly in uh oh that's
a villain on my list is speed demon
speed demon his powers from the grand
master ever heard of them pretty
powerful
and uh speed demon is like a regular
foil of spider-man i mean he's no zandu
but he's he's out there uh
but what's great about speed demon he
even impersonated the whizzer at one
point like going around doing bad things
oh the wizards
no but speed demon can run at supersonic
speeds which means he can go faster than
the speed of sound so he's pretty cool
did no one wonder when wizard was just
going way faster than 100 miles per hour
yeah
it's like wait a minute
it might not be him i don't know and
then of course you can't make a list of
fast runners and leave off quicksilver
quicksilver he's he's quick and even
though he died like a chump in the
streets in the mcu um he's showing off
some incredible speed in the comics
originally he topped out around 175
miles per hour yeah but again that was
back in the 70s that was old school
but he got some isotope e from the high
evolutionary and now he can go
supersonic he's reached a speed of mach
10 at some point so that's like 10 times
the speed of sound damn and it's
possible his true potential has not yet
been reached so he could get faster
that's pretty fast i mean that's pretty
damn fast yeah one time i was at the
club and somebody tried to offer me
isotope e and i said no because i don't
don't do drugs kids because i'm already
fast enough stay away everyone's doing
it don't know what's in it do it just
say no to isotope e then of course we
should consider tommy shepard aka speed
of the young avengers um he appears to
have inherited his super fast skills
from his uncle his uncle's quicksilver
of course the ex-gene passed down
through the family uh he claims that his
top speed is
761 miles per hour which is the speed of
sound also known as mach 1 but he's
pretty young so he could get faster over
time like his uncle you know but that's
pretty cool absolutely you know for a
young lad that's pretty insane
pretty insane another one on my list
that i really like is yo-yo
aka slingshot she's a speedster who
inherited her powers from her father via
his mutated dna she can run at very fast
speeds and what's really cool about her
when she's done using her running powers
she instantly teleports back to the spot
where she started so kind of like a
yo-yo very cute right but unfortunately
that power limits how far she can run
you know she can't go super she doesn't
get the distance she's got the
acceleration but not the distance um we
don't really know her top speed and
spoiler alert we might not know because
she's currently presumed dead in the
comics a big tower fell on her but you
know what's the comics people come back
all the time i would assume that her top
speed is zero miles per hour these days
well right now it's
zero and then of course this is a good
one this is a this is a good
good speedster gill pet perdon i might
be saying that wrong oh my god yeah aka
the runner
he's known as the runner so you know
pretty fast he's one of the elders of
the universe which makes him one of the
oldest beings uh that there is though he
said at one point like i'm 5 billion
years old and i think the universe is
like 10 billion years old so he's not
like the oldest of the elders but he's
an elder of the universe okay and he
would
regularly organize these galactic
marathons to find other speedsters in
the universe a lot of the ones i've
mentioned have like been in his races uh
he just
you know he just runs around he's like i
wanna have races and see who else is
fast and then just beat them like have
you guys heard of the boston marathon
yeah that was the run i mean he that's
nothing for him
um
his the runner's top speed is like
unknown because uh he's been known to
run tens of thousands of miles per hour
by harnessing the power primordial right
um and on planets that have atmospheres
that support life he like tones it down
he he tampers his speed so he doesn't
like run so fast that he destroys the
atmosphere and kills all the living
creatures what a nice guy right good
looking out
but yeah that that's the runner you know
what's really interesting is that uh
this gil petron the runner he's all
golden correct he's a golden man yeah
yeah he's like this beautiful golden man
well so what if
we could see the runner appear from the
sovereign race like like we were going
to see um adam warlock who is also a
golden man and the sovereign are also
golden we could also potentially see the
runner potentially come from the
sovereign race i mean he's a he's an
elder he might have been running around
on that planet when he was a young lad
yeah running around from lady to lady
and that's why they're all gold down i
don't know i just can't i don't want to
he's the father of the sovereign race he
could have been the father of the
sovereign race okay and then of course
you already mentioned her makari
she's an eternal has super speed
abilities we're gonna see her in the
internals uh upcoming eternals film you
see her in the trailer she's already
zipping around zips up um
makari can create cyclones by running in
circles uh much like carnage if you saw
let there be
uh but she does it from running uh and
she can even run across water like jesus
wow just like jesus she could easily
beat jesus in a photograph sorry
those are strong words brandon
i mean i don't know just challenge jesus
i read the bible he doesn't run that
fast i'm calling out jesus come down uh
brandon just called you out we want to
race between you and my
makari is she's so fast though uh she
was even able to beat the runner gilpet
perdan once in his galactic get out of
town get out of the town that you are in
no way the runner's crazy fast are you
serious yeah holy [ __ ] i don't think she
could do it every time but she got the
best of him one time
pretty fast pretty fast
so yeah those are some of my faves you
know this is a bite-sized question
so i couldn't cover all the runners i
don't want to hear about it don't tweet
me don't be in the comments being like
where's aurora where's black racer
where's mercury where's fast forward
where's spectrum i don't want to hear it
i don't want to hear it okay there's
tons of runners there's tons of fast
ones but these were some of my favorites
we didn't have the time to cover them
all but if i was gonna pick a fastest i
gotta go with my boy gil pet perdon the
runner he's he's fast he's a fast man
you know what i think that
the fastest runner is uh peter parker
because he uh runs from his guild oh
yeah every day he's the fastest
emotional runner exactly 100
well brandon thank you for that answer
but riddle me this brandon is the
riddler ever beaten the batman and this
is from the cantaloupe coffee on twitter
thank you cantaloupe coffee that sounds
like disgusting coffee but you sound
like a great person though so you know
people some people like a sweet coffee
that's true
it's a great question and while batman
has a pretty good track record against
his gallery of foes you know the heroes
usually went out in the end uh he does
occasionally lose just ask my boy bane
who put him in the icu baby
crap
uh batman can lose uh and we have this
upcoming the batman
film featuring the riddler of course uh
and he's inquiring minds they want to
know if the king of questions has ever
bested the cape crusader well in fact he
has uh this is a spoiler alert if you
never read batman zero year check it out
very very good very good uh but riddler
definitely gets the best of batman twice
in that storyline he cuts all the power
to gotham and he like floods the city
and batman like gets so jostled around
in that he's out of commission for a
little bit and when he comes back he
discovers that like the riddler has
taken over all of gotham and he's like
eliminating citizens who can't meet his
mental challenges which is pretty much
all of them batman of course wins out in
the end as he always does
because you got to make more batman
comics
but but the riddler definitely got the
best of him in that storyline so i'll
give that one to the riddler you did
beat him that time yo you know it'd be
crazy like while you were talking and
you said that like he uh the riddler in
zero year
did all these challenges to you know
basically test out the smartness of the
gotham population imagine if dc like
just made a squid game from with the
riddler that would be
so amazing if they did and they could
totally do it like a squid game riddler
like like movie like just the riddler i
think amazing he's doing hollywood's job
you pitch it pitch it towards it
tomorrow i'm gonna be at warner hq
tomorrow and be like hey yo nice squid
game the koreans have done it you must
do it too
but brandon now it is time for my
favorite part of the episode it's time
for the box of scraps unboxings
you know what this that's the segment
this time the cosmic cube of scraps tony
stark built this in a cave with the
cosmic cube of scraps now brandon if you
could turn one movie or series from the
mcu into a musical which one would it be
and why
oh
that's a great question mt this one
comes from crispy chrissy on discord
thank you so much crispy chrissy this is
a it's a very interesting question
because of course we're going to see
rogers the musical upcoming
film very exciting i kind of wish the
whole hawkeye series was just the music
i want to see the whole two and a half
hours of it i'm very interested yes uh
but you know i'm thinking about this
from a business standpoint you know if
you're gonna make one of these movies
into a musical you need things like you
need costumes you need like sets you
know you know interesting concepts and i
think the the first thor film would make
a pretty good musical you know what i
mean you have all those wild costumes of
asgard you know you get uh all the cool
set designs and then he gets to go down
to earth so you can make like a cool
earth and like people in those clothes
and then you have these fun songs and
it's a story of redemption for our hero
which most of the mcu stories are but
you know it's a good one you can do some
fun effects with the hammer flying
around the stage and stuff like that um
i think i think it would make a pretty
good musical and plus you know in asgard
they have the acting troop yeah good
musicals they have the show within the
show you could have that happen at some
point yeah in the musical oh my god my
vote is for the first store let's let's
put it on broadway 2023 baby yo i want
you at marvel studios tomorrow pitching
that yes oh my god that's a one i love
that especially with the the thor
asgardian troop that would be freaking
priceless we gotta call it thor turn off
the lightning
no no no no
don't don't bring out don't worry about
it
but i think for me
honestly i think i would probably do
guardians of the galaxy i think because
like
because it's a very
musical
um series on its own so i just feel like
having like a musical with 70s rock
songs would be like a good jukebox
musical yeah i mean it would be so much
fun like we could have a guy in a groot
costume we could have a little a little
man in a rocket costume it would be like
lion king with the big group costume
coming out and we got to put it on ice
let's just do it guardian of the galaxy
on ice musical and it's just like it's
skating oh now they're on ice yeah okay
i like this that's dangerous it would be
so much it should be so good um but yeah
i think guardians of the galaxy would be
really fun but i like yours better
honestly
broadway needs that so it's clear
exactly we're gonna win tony's we're
gonna this is our we're on our way to an
egot right now um i'm telling you right
now but that is it for this episode of
big question i want to thank off-screen
producer brandon we're still going to
call him off-screen producer brandon for
the end of time so please stop
complaining that's his name
i just love the joke uh please follow
him at grindenberric he's an amazing man
who does amazing things it tweets
amazing things so please follow them
there follow me at mastertainment if you
want to see between some weird [ __ ] but
most importantly follow at new rockstars
on twitter but also here on youtube and
please hit that notification bell so you
can get notifications whenever we upload
a new video and please hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com so you can get cool
shirts like this and our venom shirts
and our all our cool shirts um there so
you can uh get a cool nerdy girlfriend
or boyfriend or whatever partner um that
you would like
that's it
this is coming from my single ass so
that's a lie um
you know what get shirts for yourself
yes live for yourself live for yourself
you don't need no you know partner
they'll only disappoint you at the end
but anyways thank you guys again for
watching we'll see you guys later we
love you goodbye
[Music]
you